Auckland International Airport
welcomes over
350,000 visitors from the USA every year.
Many bring dreams of a wonderful holiday,
but this woman
has brought a biosecurity nightmare.
I've just seen the most incredible thing,
a cat.
And the lady says It's a live cat.
That's a first for me.
I've never seen that before.
You can't bring a live
cat into New Zealand.
Not this way.
Not through the x-ray.
Um, that’s a huge biosecurity risk,
I’m going have to go, I’m
going to talk to her now about it.
The cat and its American owner
are separated immediately.
Biosecurity Officer Demi
quickly carries the cat to a secure lab
to prevent the spread
of any infectious diseases,
while officer Phil confronts the owner.
I want to talk to you
about the declaration side
of things alright, because live animals
coming into New Zealand
are a big thing for us, diseases
obviously.
Yeah, because it is an offense
to bring, or attempt to bring um, an item
such as a live animal
which is about as big as we get,
into the country without declaring it.
The woman doesn't understand
how serious this is.
But Phil does.
There'll be no winners here.
Auckland’s
International Mail Centre processes
an amazing 7,000 parcels and packets
every hour.
Today Customs officer
Alannah is monitoring the mail belt
when she spots an ordinary box
just in from China.
It’s declared as a doll, but out the back,
Alannah thinks it might be more than that.
So I have this parcel
I found today at the belts, it’s
declared a doll but it definitely
looks like there’s something inside here
so I’m going to open it up
and take a look at it.
The declaration matches the contents
but on turning the toy over,
Alannah notices
tell-tale signs of tampering.
Quite a heavy doll,
um we can clearly see it’s been tampered
with, very poor stitching
which is actually coming undone.
Nobody wants to tear apart
a toy for no good reason.
So Alana, X-rays it one more time,
looking at the X-ray image that appears
to be contained within a sealed bag.
So I'm going to go ahead and
cut it open and examine it.
It seems the game is up.
The toy is hiding something
and after some work
with a knife, Alannah finds a foil bag.
The packet concealed within the soft toy,
It's quite heavy and quite a dense
crystal-like substance.
So, because we can’t test it here
using the first defender, we will take it
over to our secure exhibits room
where we will be able to open it up
and take a sample
and test it in our- a secure
safe environment.